you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
a new oil and gas field is approved in
the north sea containing 5.5 million
barrels of oil
the government considers options to keep
energy prices down for households with
the energy price cap rise to be
announced tomorrow
and a deal to help end deforestation has
missed its first deadline just months
after it was signed a cop 26.
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now the north sea has for a
long time been a source of oil and gas
for the uk but drilling for fossil fuels
is a dirty business and in its cop 26
commitments the uk government has
promised to be a world leader in
tackling climate change but now a new
oil and gas field in the north sea has
been approved by the uk government
called abigail it will contain 5.5
million barrels of oil equivalent which
campaigners say is too small to justify
the extraction
skies climate correspondent hannah
thomas peter has been speaking to the
oil and gas authority about the future
of drilling in the north sea and has
this report
we're right in the middle of the comedy
first at the moment ember gordon behind
us
on the northeast coast of scotland there
is a stretch of water that is home to
the ghost rigs
these extraordinary structures brought
here from the oil and gas fields of the
north sea
some for repairs others left to rust
for boat operator david grant they are
symbols of an industry in transition
lots changed over the years here the
rigs were built here and now they're
being taken now they're being taken
apart here yeah and i suppose they're
going to renewables now as well you know
well all wind it's all wind now isn't it
for those rigs that remain in operation
the other challenge is cleaning up
drilling and extraction is a dirty
carbon intensive business the uk's north
sea oil and gas industry is supposed to
be halving its operational carbon
emissions by 2030 and getting to net
zero by 2050 but when you get up close
to these things and you see just how
huge and complicated they are you also
get a sense of just how challenging that
decarbonization process is going to be
but whatever the difficulties port
director rory gunn is convinced fossil
fuels have staying power
even as he shows us the new wind
turbines he's helping to build i think
that if you look at the amount of
products that we use on a day-to-day
basis that are only there because of oil
and gas
and you look at the the challenges we
have on energy supply in the uk as we
see with our rising utility bills etc i
think there has to be a grown-up
discussion and a realization that uh oil
and gas is essential and it will be for
decades to come
that is exactly the calculation the
government has made its regulator the
oil and gas authority continues to
approve new projects in the north sea
most recently an oil and gas field
called abigail
if the uk is a climate change leader
why on earth are we even considering
approving new fields i understand the
argument i
it's a difficult and very complex
situation to to come to the right answer
on but if we
stop new developments the uk will just
become more dependent on imports and
we'll reduce our own security of supply
options
campaigners disagree the only route to
both energy security and net zero
targets they say is the rapid end of
fossil fuels
there is absolutely no room for growing
uh the supply of oil gas in the uk or
anywhere international energy
agency the world's leading energy think
tank declared twice last year that
there's enough oil and gas in the world
in production right now
to take us beyond the limits of the
glasgow climate agreement the paris
climate agreement we just don't need to
look for any more
the tension over a declining industry
that helped build our modern world is
playing out now in the north sea
the ghost rigs of chromity firth a
reminder of the uncertainty ahead hannah
thomas peter sky news in scotland
well new data released to us at the
daily climate show has revealed that
north sea oil and gas production in 2021
was the dirtiest it's been for five
years when records began the research by
reichstag also shows that despite a
recent pledge to halve emissions oil and
gas extracted in the uk releases more
co2 per barrel than many other developed
oil producing economies so let's take a
look at some of that data now and
although absolute carbon emissions from
north sea operations are falling
projections suggest that the intensity
of those carbon emissions rose by 15
last year compared to the year before
now that's mainly because of major
repair works to a pipeline but also
because it's getting harder to extract
oil and gas from aging reserves
13
of the emissions produced are from
flaring that's a controversial method of
burning off waste or other unwanted
gases
the carbon intensity of the uk oil and
gas industry has been improving since
2018 but the figures for 2021 show a
rise of three kilograms of carbon
dioxide per barrel of oil equivalent
meaning the uk's oil and gas extraction
operations produce 23 kilograms of
carbon dioxide
per barrel of oil equivalent last year
now that is the highest since records
began
the oil and gas authorities told sky
news that although it does consider
emissions intensity it's focused on
bringing down total carbon emissions in
line with industry commitments
and i'll be discussing some of the
concerns around north sea oil a little
bit later in the show with fatima
ibrahim from the green new deal uk and
professor of political economy at the
university of sheffield michael jacobs
now for some of the day's other climate
news and five insulate britain activists
have been jailed at the high court after
breaching an injunction by protesting on
the m25 last year national highways
launched legal action against the group
after defying an order banning them from
blocking roads on the motorway they'll
spend between 24 and 42 days in jail 11
others were given suspended
sentences the uk's tallest birds the
common crane have had their most
successful year since the 17th century
the latest breeding survey showed that
there are a record-breaking 72 pairs
with 65 birds breeding 40 chicks they're
now estimated to be over 200 common
cranes in the uk
but the habitat is degrading at a faster
rate than forests today is the first
united nations sanctioned world wetlands
day almost 90 percent of the delicate
ecosystems have been degrading since the
1700s
drainage and climate change continue to
threaten their existence
the energy regulator ofgem is expected
to announce the energy cap rise tomorrow
morning bringing it forward by a week
the government is now considering how to
keep household bills down and the impact
of climate policy could feature in that
debate ofgem's announcement will
coincide with the decision from the bank
of england on whether to further raise
interest rates and we'll have full
coverage on those announcements tomorrow
here on the daily climate show
the government has been urged to stop
making owners of electric vehicles who
can't charge at home pay four times more
tax for their power campaigners want the
current 20 rate on energy at public
charge points to match the 5 domestic
rate which applies to drivers who have
the facilities at home
more than 74 000 people have signed an
online petition insisting ministers make
electric vehicles fairer and more
affordable before it's too late
now deforestation was one of the key
commitments at cop 26 and one of the
first announcements at the summit in
glasgow but now sky news can reveal the
deforestation deal has missed its first
deadline so let's take a look at that in
more detail and over the past 20 years
tree cover has decreased by 10 percent
10 and the rate of deforestation is
estimated at 10 million hectares per
year accord 26 more than 100 leaders
representing 85 of the world's forests
committed to stopping and reversing
deforestation by 2030. now the
commitment is backed by 14 billion
pounds of public and private funding
included in that a group of donor
countries promised 500 million dollars
to the democratic republic of congo to
protect the congo basin which absorbs
four percent of the world's carbon
dioxide but is suffering widespread
forest loss
well our climate change reporter
victoria seabrook is here with me now so
victoria what exactly has gone wrong
here well yes so in return for this 500
million dollars about 370 million pounds
that was promised to the drc by a group
of donor countries signed by boris
johnson to some fanfare during cop26 in
return the drc was supposed to publish
an audit of all of its existing logging
concessions permits effectively and the
idea is that this would help to weed out
some of those that were illegal so
that's those which are not ensuring
biodiversity protection or protection
for indigenous and front-line
communities and so the reason why this
audit matters is because campaigners say
you can't start to tackle the illegal
deforestation if you don't even have a
handle on the numbers and they believe
it to be perhaps 22 illegal contracts
maybe in the 60s and 70s
greenpeace africa they say that this was
a botched deal designed to sort of grab
headlines full of glitzy statements and
they say that this was always doomed to
fail this deal because it wasn't
conditional on actually stopping all new
logging concessions
on the other hand others would say well
none of this money has actually changed
hands yet and that shows how the deal is
working because if commitments aren't
filled if these conditions and terms
aren't met the money isn't flowing and
that's right that's how it should work
now it's still early days the deal was
only signed in november and this audit
was supposed to be published by the end
of last year it's missed that deadline
but of course it is due it may still be
published it's due to be soon but this
is how we start to test whether these
deals are really going to work
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
fatima ibrahim from the green new deal
uk and professor of political economy at
the university of sheffield michael
jacobs so hello to both of you good
evening good evening
so first of all if governments are
serious about the climate crisis there
can be no new investments in oil and gas
the words of international energy chief
fatibiro last year it was a sentiment
echoed recently by alex sharma who leads
the uk government's climate policy but
now we learn of a new north sea oil
field being approved and the uk oil and
gas authority continue to argue for new
developments so fatima first of all what
do you make of the approval of this new
oil field
i mean it's unconscionable that we are
having this conversation in 2022 about
new oil fields we have a huge task ahead
of us to transition away from dirty
fossil fuels and to be opening new oil
fields that really
the uk taxpayer doesn't um isn't set to
gain much from it
it won't create that many jobs and the
only winners are the corporations and
the companies involved and it sets us
even further back from being able to
meet our climate targets when we have
huge opportunities to invest in
renewables that will give us energy
security because we can create them at
home it will help us reduce our energy
bills in this energy crisis so i mean
it's just hard for me to understand why
the government continues to approve
these new dirty fossil fuel projects and
this is just one of 39 that they're set
to approve this year well michael the
government has addressed this issue
haven't they of investments in the north
sea and when they do they talk about how
they're working hard to reduce the
demand for fossil fuels but in the
meantime they say that there will be
ongoing demand for oil and gas over the
coming years as the as we transition
towards uh lower carbon alternatives and
they talk about this issue of energy
security and jobs as well so what do you
make of that argument
well there is an energy security
argument uh we get a lot of our energy
from
places that are relatively unstable
abroad although to be perfectly honest
energy supplies have not been that
unstable
but we have seen as we are experiencing
in the moment that
producer nations of oil and gas can
restrict supply increase the price and
then of course that has a huge impact as
it is now on the cost of living
as your report earlier uh showed so
there is an energy security argument but
the climate argument is the one about
the future of the entire planet and as
the international energy agency said
last year um and as uh somebody said on
your package um there is no room for
additional energy production of fossil
fuels
we are going to exceed the carbon budget
that will limit global warming to two
degrees or one and a half degrees with
all the uh oil and gas that has already
been explored and is in production so
this is really where the kind of the the
sheep get sorted from the goats it's
very easy
um and all politicians are now very
happy to say we should have more
renewable energy
the difficult thing which some
politicians including this government as
is seen today have not been willing to
say is we must also have less fossil
fuel energy and there really is no room
the climate science is very clear about
this there is no room for further
extraction if we're going to hold global
temperature to safe levels so this is a
real test for the government and i'm
afraid it hasn't it hasn't passed that
test today and fatima the government
might argue that this latest oil field
abigail contains only 5.5 million
barrels of oil equivalent it's not huge
and they would say
we feel we can tolerate these projects
and still meet our climate targets which
are ambitious
but this project doesn't even touch the
sides if we're talking about energy
security or providing energy for the
taxpayers it's just simply not going to
provide or solve any of the problems
that we have so this is doesn't make
business sense it doesn't make economic
sense i mean it's really hard to
understand and make the case that this
energy project is one that's worth
investing in and it's worth taking the
risk of us furthering uh
falling further into the climate crisis
because it actually isn't solving any of
the problems that the climate is that
the government is saying that it's
trying to solve so it's a bad business
project okay simply even if we don't
care about the climate and very very
briefly michael um the government would
say it can hit its targets they will
point out where look at the amount of
money that's going into wind power in
this country for example we're doing the
right thing there
we are doing the right thing on wind
power although there's not enough going
into onshore wind but the simple fact
remains that new exploration of oil and
gas increases the global total of carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gas
emissions and that is not possible
within the budgets that the government
has set itself to it's not just about
this country it's about the global total
we're very unlikely to consume much of
the energy from this new field it'll go
into the global supply and that is
exceeding the carbon budget that will
allow global temperature to be uh kept
to safe levels and that is the simple
hard fact of climate change as we're
experiencing it now i'm going to crack
on with the next subject now if that's
all right because we want to talk about
a freedom of information request from
the carbon brief website which today
revealed details of a briefing on
climate change given to boris johnson
shortly after his arrival in downing
street now the chief scientific advisor
patrick valance laid out the science of
global warming the role of carbon and
the devastating likely future impacts
and now we're not all lucky enough to
have a personal briefing from the
country's top scientists so what is the
best way to get through to people
whether that's world leaders or the
public at large so fatima yeah we
haven't all got the chief scientific
advisor to run us through a few slides
have we so what do you think the best
way to communicate the message on
climate change is
yeah i mean i had a wonderful
conversation today with the
the head of the institute of physics
about how you know we need to be better
about communicating the nuances of
climate science we can sometimes you
know extrapolate top lines from the
climate science that uh don't build
trust with the public um whether it's
like we've got 10 years left to save the
world or not even communicating using
the right terms talking about 1.5
degrees when 1.5 degrees doesn't mean
anything to the average person and so i
think we could be doing better about
taking the time to explain you know the
risks that are posed by inaction but
also talking about the solutions
pointing towards the vision of the
future that people can tangibly see and
not just speaking about the problems and
the wealth of knowledge that exists in
both science and technology about what
the future can look like and we can do
that by working with scientists and we
could the media could also be better
platforming science scientists uh
because they are great communicators and
they are trustworthy communicators i
think the film don't look up was a
really great example of how you know
scientists are currently just stuck in
this room
know the evidence have the facts and are
just trying to get it out there and we
could be platforming them the scientists
are trusted across the public maybe more
so than you know activists are
that's that's so interesting and getting
the message over to the public is
clearly really important michael isn't
it but also to to politicians and you
know all about advising politicians
don't you so what's the way to get your
message across to those who can play a
real role in shaping policy
yeah i think it depends very much on
their prior level of knowledge i was a
bit shocked when i looked at these uh
slides and the email exchanges that
accompanied them well done to carbon
brief the freedom of information request
to get hold of them they were really
climate science 101 this was not about
the economic costs and benefits of
different technologies and solutions to
the climate crisis this was really about
the fact that greenhouse gas emissions
cause temperature to rise and
temperature rises
have huge devastating environmental and
social effects and i was really rather
shocked that the prime minister needed
such a basic introduction to climate
science and climate impacts um when he
became prime minister really we should
expect our politicians to be better
informed but well done for him for
asking for that briefing well done for
the scientists to explain it to him and
it obviously had some effect he changed
his view and in the end we've got to
live with the politicians we have at
least for the moment and we've got to
work with them uh to get them not just
to understand the science but also
themselves how to communicate it in ways
that they feel okay will bring the
public along okay that's the
in the end the point the politicians
will respond to the public so it's also
about how we talk to the public okay
yeah and a very brief last thought on
that fatima some people just don't want
to hear the message especially when it
can seem quite grim
i'm just going to end with what michael
said which is you know boris johnson is
a populist why did he ask for this
report because when he became prime
minister in 2019 we had this map mass
mobilizations he knew the public was
concerned about uh climate change he
wanted to know more and be seen to be
acting on it so actually the best way we
convince our leaders is by taking to the
streets and showing them what's the most
important priority we want them to act
on okay we're going to leave it there
fatima ibrahim michael jacobs really
interesting to get your take on things
thanks very much indeed